hey this is presh talwalkar
alice and bob can complete a job in two
hours
alice and charlie can complete the same
job in three hours
bob and charlie can complete the same
job in 4 hours
how long will the job take if alice bob
and charlie work together
assume each person works at a constant
rate whether working alone or working
with others
this problem has been asked to students
in u.s colleges
to the professor's surprise
many of the students set up the wrong
equations and could not solve this
problem
can you figure it out
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for the
solution
before i get to the solution let me go
over a common mistake in how students
get to the wrong answer
they read the first sentence that alice
and bob can complete a job in two hours
and translate the names and the numbers
into an equation
they say this must mean that a plus b
equals two
they look at the second sentence that
alice and charlie can complete the job
in three hours and they similarly
convert it to a plus c equals three
the third condition that bob and charlie
can complete the job in four hours gets
converted to the equation b plus c
equals four
the question of how long it will take
for all three of them working together
gets translated into the question of
what is a plus b plus c
so to solve this system of equations
they want to solve for a plus b plus c
so they can add up all the equations
together
we end up getting two terms of a two
terms of b and two terms of c to equal
two plus three plus four
if we group the vectors we get two a
plus two b plus two c
equals nine
we then divide by two
and that gets us to a plus b plus c
equals nine halves which equals four
fifths
so evidently this will be the answer
that many students get
they would say that it takes 4.5 hours
for all three of them when working
together
but let's think about does this answer
make any sense we know that alice and
bob take two hours
alice and charlie take three hours
and bob and charlie take four hours
but somehow when all three are working
together they take four and a half hours
this makes no sense when three people
work together it should take less time
than when only two people work together
but 4.5 hours is more time
so this answer must be wrong
not only were the equations set up
incorrectly but any student who submits
this answer is not thinking about
whether the answer makes any logical
sense
so how do we solve this problem
we need to set up the equations in the
correct method
we know that alice and bob can complete
a job in two hours
so how do we translate this into an
equation
well if they complete the job in two
hours that means the percentage of the
job that alice does in two hours plus
the percentage of the job that bob does
in two hours equals one hundred percent
or that equals one
now since they work at a constant rate
we can say
the amount of the job that alice does in
two hours is two times the amount of the
job that she does in one hour and the
same thing goes for bob
so we now have a natural choice for our
variables
we can say the percentage of the job
that alice does in one hour will be the
variable a
and the percentage of the job that bob
does in one hour will be the variable b
this leads to the equation
that two a plus two b equals one
and that's how we can translate this we
can group this out to be two times the
quantity a plus b equals one
so we can now translate the second
sentence we have alice and charlie
completing the job in three hours
this would translate into three times
the quantity a plus c equals one or c is
the percentage of the job that charlie
completes in one hour
we also have that bob and charlie can
complete the job in four hours so that
would mean four times the quantity b
plus c equals one
now we want to figure out what would
happen if the all three work together
so we are needing to solve for the time
times the quantity a plus b plus c
equals one
we need to solve for this variable t
so how do we do that
well we can similarly add up all the
equations but we have different
quantities of each of these variables so
in order to get the same number of each
variable we're going to do a little
trick
we're going to multiply each equation so
that there's a leading coefficient of 12
which is the lowest common multiple of 2
3 and 4.
so the first equation we'll multiply by
six
this will get twelve times the quantity
a plus b to be equal to six
the second equation will multiply by
four
and the third equation will multiply by
three
we can now add up all of these equations
we'll end up with 12a two times 12b two
times and 12c two times and this will be
equal to six plus four plus three
we can factor out the 24 of each of
these variables and that will be equal
to 6 plus 4 plus 3 which equals 13.
we now divide by 13
and we end up with 24 divided by 13
times the quantity a plus b plus c
equals one
and that is what we wanted to figure out
so we go back to our setup and we can
see that we get to the answer of 24 over
13.
so the job will take 24 over 13 hours or
about 1 hour and 51 minutes and this is
a sensible answer because it takes less
time than any pair working together
did you figure this out
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math you can catch me on my blog mind
your decisions which you can follow on
facebook google plus and patreon you can
catch me on social media at
preshtalwalker and if you like this
video please check out my books there
are links in the video description